how many videos should you do per week
so i got a question from a friend of
mine her name is bailey
and she's asking me how many videos
should she do per week to tell her story
now let me back up and tell you a little
bit about bailey
bailey has a successful company called
proactive movement
she's built this thing up over the past
couple years has had great results for
her clients they love her
she just feels like there's something
missing in her life like there's
something
more that she could give to the world
than what she's doing right now
her company will always be a part of her
she's always pouring energy into it but
but she's meant for something greater
and this is something that i think
everybody can relate to
at least i hope you can relate to right
do you feel like in your business or in
your life
you are meant for something greater than
what you're doing right now
and so i encourage you to say bailey you
need to document this
because what she's doing now is she's
going on a journey of self-discovery
she's trying a whole bunch of new stuff
she's traveling she's signing up for
courses
she's learning from mentors she's
practicing speaking she's practicing
videos she's trying out a whole bunch of
new stuff
to see where her path is this is really
important because for most people
they're afraid to take that step you
might be thinking to yourself
i i i don't know what i'm doing with my
life i feel like i deserve
better i feel like i could contribute
way more to this world
but you're too afraid to take the next
step
you're too afraid to start that journey
of exploration
so i told people you have to document
you got to record this
because i know you're gonna find your
path my friend bailey is gonna find her
path
she is gonna be a force to be reckoned
with in this world i know it
i believe it it's gonna happen but right
now
she doesn't know how it's all going to
work out she doesn't know what her path
is going to look like she doesn't know
who she's going to meet she doesn't know
what she's going to be doing
she's discovering and this is an
important journey
that everybody has to go on at least
once
in their life and this right now this is
the the
the most important part because
bailey in a couple years saying how she
became successful
is not his interest in the story what's
really important is this this is the
scary stuff
this is the uncertainty this is the
vulnerability this is the i don't know
what i'm doing now
that journey will help inspire
other people hopefully like you who are
going through the same thing but are too
afraid to take that step
seeing bailey do it will help inspire
others to take action with their own
life and so she writes to me and
says you know should i do it once a week
i don't know if that's
if that's too much to do i don't know if
i have enough to say in the week
so here's my two bits of advice and this
is for everybody who's trying to
document their journey
and get some stuff up on youtube or
wherever you're going to post it to help
inspire others
first of all you need to practice okay
one video per week should be
minimum minimum you want to be a speaker
you want to gain an audience you want to
build a movement
one video a week is a minimum
first of all because you need to
practice
you need to get better right as good as
bailey is
right now the people watching her videos
are just her friends sorry bailey i'm
being honest
but she has the potential
to impact millions of people and for
that to happen
she has to get better on camera now
she's done like two videos
and her her first two videos are way
better
than my first two videos she has a
natural ability
that is way better than what i started
with but she still has to get a lot
better and that comes from practice i've
gotten better with my videos because i
practice
i've done over a thousand videos you go
back even six months on my channel
and compare it with today and you'll see
the progress i wanna
i wanna remove my first videos because i
look back and
say oh my it's so bad that is so bad
but people still like them people still
watch them so i keep them up and it's
fun to see
how i've progressed through practice so
one per week is
minimum i do 14 per week
you got to do at least one per week okay
just to develop the skill set to get
better at speaking in front of the
camera and connecting with people
the second thing is this is really
important the types of videos that you
practice
so right now bailey's videos are
are summarizing what's happened to her
so i've taken this course and
and it was really great and now next
week i'm gonna go for this interview
and basically what she's doing with her
life and that that's great the problem
is
there's no feeling what would be way
more powerful
is take one moment that happened to you
in the past week
ideally you're recording it just after
it happened so it's still fresh
and just tell me about that moment
because your goal here is to make me
feel something good or bad
right most of us think about the good
things right i just landed this new deal
or i just signed up a new client or i
just got into this new program
or i just got a new mentor all the good
stuff right that's great
but the more powerful stuff is is on the
negative side
tell me about how nervous you are or how
scared you are
be vulnerable make me feel something
tell me one
story in depth and make me
feel like i'm with you right if you're
nervous i want to be nervous if you're
crying i want to be crying
take me on that journey instead of
summarizing what happened to you
and hopefully this gives you a lot more
stories to be able to practice and be
able to tell
the reason why it's so important is
because the goal of these videos
is not just to document your own
progress which is great
but to help inspire other people to do
the same thing
to help inspire millions of people to
look at their life and say i could do
better
and to inspire them and to move them to
action you have to make them
feel something if they don't feel
anything if they don't feel connection
to you they're not going to listen to
your advice
make them feel how important it is for
you
and draw them in and bailey's great at
this bailey isn't a
she has she wears her heart on her
sleeve she's she's
emotional which is great it just is not
coming across yet on camera
so this is a skill to practice so once a
week minimum
and instead of summarizing give me
specifics take me deep make me feel the
pain
make me feel the happiness bring me
along i want to be
deep inside your story make that happen
and you can connect with people and
you're starting your movement
belief so i'm clearly i'm sick and my
voice is really funny
but um i haven't recorded for the past
couple of weeks and evan has been
knocking on my door and saying why are
you recording anything and i've been
saying because i've been so busy
and he said no excuses you still need to
pump out one video a week when you're
feeling inspired when you're feeling
down when you're feeling busy no matter
what so yes i failed i'm here sick and
still recording
for those of you watching you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
let me know what you think if you agree
disagree leave it in the comments below
if you have a question
put it below make a video response and
if you want click on my face subscribe
to the channel
thank you guys so much i'll see you soon